Let's study the botnet C&C problem.
The key question here is that
how can the bot master know
which computers have been infected?
In other words,
how can the bot master contact
the infected machines and use them?
Let's think like a bot master for
a moment.
The easiest way to think of,
is to have the victims or
the compromised computers to contact us.
So, okay, let's do this.
The first step is to create the malware.
We call it vx.
So for example we can download
some example vx code from the web,
fiddle around it, compile it, okay?
To make sure that it works.
Then, we can use email to publicate it.
For example, using social engineering to
send it to some people that we know, and
from there it will spread.
That is, we create a malware,
we spread it through email.
Spreading is the easy part, but
now what if we want to make
use of these victim computers?